i've been thinking about this uh i woke
up in the middle of the night a couple
of days ago and had this
title for an idea that i've been
considering for a while so i'm going to
give it to you because i feel like this
might be your sort of thing so hedonic
adaptation is when
you're consistent desire for material
wealth continues to move as you acquire
new and nicer and better things right
that's hedonic adaptation um i think
that there's an equivalent called
imposter adaptation so the imposter
syndrome which is when you do not feel
like you are worthy of any successes
that you are having in life and that you
don't feel like you're supposed to be
here i don't have the expertise that has
put me into the position i'm in right
over time
you can continue to
disprove your own imposter syndrome you
are put into a situation you defeat the
situation you come out victorious you've
done really really well
and yet your imposter syndrome continues
to exist
you continue to beat it in reality and
yet mentally it is always there i'm
still not supposed to be here i'm still
not supposed to be here the way that i
see it if you continue to defeat your
imposter syndrome in the real world and
your imposter syndrome persists
after a while you have to admit to
yourself that this has got nothing to do
with your competence and everything to
do with the addiction to being an
imposter so this is the imposter
adaptation that i came up with that is
brilliant and that is absolutely the
case
i have not used that particular
terminology
but i have observed the same thing over
and over and over
um
an ice hockey player
you know
oh wow now i am playing junior
professional hockey in north america
uh
i gotta get used to this new level of
play
i'm not really comfortable
i get kind of comfortable
and on the basis of my success at that
level now i get to play at the north
american university level
oh once again that doubt that imposter
rears
his ugly head
and you have the same experience at this
new level
you have to defeat it there
and then after your university
experience
you're invited to a to a professional um
national hockey league
situation organization oh do i belong
here
and i've even seen it persist once a
fella has made it through uni juniors
made it through university made it onto
a national hockey league roster become
the starter
on that roster once again there's an
adjustment and then once he even once
he's a starter oh i'm going to play in
the montreal forum a legendary arena
oh i'm going to play against um
one of the future hall of famers in the
league oh now i'm going to play in the
playoffs at the end of the season each
of those steps in the career
reinvigorate
the tendency to feel like an imposter
like you don't belong and so you've got
to constantly keep working at it
at each level at each level at each
level in some ways it never really goes
away and this is what
you know again i come back to this
don't think ladies and gentlemen that
confidence is this all-encompassing
thing don't think that once you've got
it
you'll have it forever
there is no atomic bomb you can drop on
it to destroy it
to destroy that enemy
it's a constant ongoing
war of attrition to use a military
analogy
so yeah that imposter
can continue to
lurk inside you and i love the way you
put it you got to realize that it's not
your competence that's holding you back
it's your own sense of self
so let's work on that let's really work
on being selective and careful with what
we remember let's really work on being
selective and careful and in how we
think about ourselves and our skill
level in the present let's be very
selective and careful about the pictures
we create
for the possible futures that we want
and let's make the right choices at each
of those levels
is there a degree of
delusion that's appropriate for people
in this case to try and well i don't
know whether delusion is the right word
you're selectively choosing particular
things that create a engender a certain
frame of mind moving forward i forget
the failures i focus on the successes i
forget the failures i focus on the
successes um
in your mind is there ever a concern of
taking that too far is there such a
thing as overconfidence
i think there might be
but my experience
30 plus years of doing this work
29 years here at west point
is that there is a
far greater tendency
to be
under confident
to not believe in the actual level of
skill and capability that you do indeed
have
i can only count
on the fingers of one hand
the cases that i've encountered
where somebody was just ridiculously
inaccurate
in the match up between their actual
skill level and their belief in their
skill level you know
to the point where they were
as you would put it overconfident um
that only becomes a problem
when
your level of confidence your belief in
yourself prevents you from doing the
requisite training
and practicing
you got to have you got to be a
workhorse for sure
but you want to match that with a
racehorse as uh i like to use the
analogy
a certain extent getting back to your
point about delusion
i think there is a certain degree of
functional delusion that is very
powerful
again we use our imagination
to think about how we want to be
well we're not there yet so isn't that
by definition a little bit delusional
and
i don't think it's any stretch to state
that
everyone's personal
breakthroughs the great accomplishments
in human history
were all preceded by a certain degree of
delusion
you know roger bannister said that in
order to run a sub 4 minute mile
you have to be humble enough to do the
work
and then you have to be arrogant enough
to think that you can actually do it
i think sir roger was dead on that
degree of arrogance i can do this well
that's a form of delusion
even all of us when we were young kids
trying to ride a bicycle for the first
time without the training wheels
okay
we couldn't do it
we had never done it before
but we yet entertained a certain
concept a certain idea
a certain vision
that we could indeed do it
and
without that
pre-existing vision
we never would have gotten back on the
bike
after having
run off the road fall and scraped our
knees the first couple times that we
tried it
so yes there is a degree of functional
delusion which i think is very important
for human performance
i think you're right as well that
most people undershoot their confidence
as opposed to overshooting it the vast
vast vast majority of people that i know
are they're in need of more not less
indeed what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace